We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P. speaking
of ignorance, that is exactly what this voicemail
question is about.
Take a listen.
Hey David, I was just going to make us question
click on what's your opinion on Americans
excepting there's self inflicted ignorance.
Thank you.
Have a good day.
Yeah,
I, I would actually put it a different way.
It's not about Americans accepting self-inflicted
ignorance.
There are Americans who wear that ignorance
like a badge of honor because they have been
bamboozled by the Republican party into believing
education is liberal indoctrination.
Um, you don't need to be, you know, history.
Who cares what other countries think and do,
who cares?
We're America, we do what we want.
We know what is best.
We know what is right.
It doesn't matter what anybody else does.
So it's actually worse than merely accepting
that self-inflicted ignorance.
It is a movement that wears it as a badge
of honor and that is the scariest part of
it.
And, um, I, I don't know what is going to
turn it around.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
A Republican candidate has been charged with
distributing fake sample ballots on election
day.
Krispy Kreme donuts has struck a very interesting
deal with a college kid who drives hundreds
of miles to resell their donuts, and we will
talk about a very interesting study out of
Japan about the four day work week, not Tim
Ferriss's four hour work week.
We're not there yet, but the four day work
week, all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show, I hope you'll join us there.
You can get instant access by becoming a member
at David pakman.com/membership or a patron
at Patriots [inaudible]
dot com slash David pack and show the David
Pakman show@davidpakman.com.